[Music]  Nicole Kidman and Keith Urban show off  their beach bods in the australian waves  the couple who are both 49 hit the  Sydney Shore with their daughters Sunday  rose and faith Margaret on Monday  looking as youthful and in love as ever  that you just made up for it I have met  each other we always say that this is  why they're my favorite couple  always Lissa : he celebrated their  10-year anniversary in June here's what  they told et what is your secret to  staying together in Hollywood because  ten years in Hollywood that's a huge  dating keep dating your wife that's it  special date nights yeah I'm still  trying to get her to go out with me  that's what I'm trying to do to ruin  Nicole yeah exactly